the Republican chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee also leveling some
new and serious allegations tonight
that's right ready to a Senate Democrat
chairman chuck Grassley questioned the
accuracy of testimony given by the
co-founder of the firm behind the Trump
dossier in August fusion GPS co-founder
Glenn Simpson told Senate investigators
that his firms work on the Trump dossier
and did in November 2016 Grassley writes
quote that was extremely misleading if
not an outright lie contrary to mr.
Simpson's denial in the staff interview
according to the FBI and others Fusion
actually did continue Trump dossier work
for a new client after the election the
new client was Daniel Jones a former
staffer for Democratic Senator Dianne
Feinstein according to Grassley Jones
and his firm hired Simpson to continue
the rush of research so that it could be
shared with Capitol Hill the FBI and the
media after the election
neither Jones nor Simpson responded to
Fox's questions today Grassley said
their statements are covered by the
federal statute that makes it a crime to
lie to federal investigators Brett
follow asides death and deaths